Here's a quote from Tony Wasserman about detail design.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The primary activity during detail design, is designing the data structures that
are there and by implication the algorithms that are going to work on
those data structures. As far as those algorithms are concerned,
sometimes you may wish to represent them using some kind of design notation.
Here are a few that have been used in the past in which you may have little
familiarity. Their pseudo code, which is like writing a programming language
algorithm without the programming language. There's structured programming,
which is a set of control structures,
which allow you to organize the algorithm into sequences,
conditions, repetition, and chunking in the form of calling subprocedures.
Flow charts and call graphs are graphic representations of programs,
that may be useful in helping you understand how that program is going to,
going to work. And in some cases decision tables, which are lists of rules and
the conditions under which those rules are going to apply,
can be useful in helping to understand complex situations.